[Music]
from battling alongside xena to painting
with beeswax here's what the actor who
played gabrielle has been up to lately
just as xena warrior princess helped put
renee o'connor on the map it also
kick-started her love for directing the
actor got the opportunity to direct the
xena season 4 finale and she later
helmed an episode in season six
after her time on xena warrior princess
o'connor founded roc productions and
went on to direct award-winning shorts
as well as some lesser-known full-length
films she co-directed diamonds and guns
as her first feature film directing
credit while starring in the project and
acting as executive producer you
recognize me according to o'connor the
move from acting on screen in a tv show
for six years to the production side of
things came with a steep learning curve
she produced a number of shorts
including words unspoken which won her
awards for best short film and best
actress at the west hollywood
international film festival when asked
what inspired her to direct words
unspoken o'connor told film nut i wanted
to direct something where i didn't have
to compromise to a studio such as to a
television show i could really just be
authentic in my own voice and in my own
visions it seems like she ran with that
wish as o'connor went on to direct her
second feature film broken things a few
years later in 2015. in 2017 watch the
sky was released o'connor played a dual
role in the family sci-fi film appearing
on screen while also acting as executive
producer
somewhere between beasting out as
gabrielle on xena warrior princess and
diving into different roles on movie
sets renee o'connor tackled the biggest
job of all creating and raising a family
she married her first husband steve muir
while still playing gabrielle and she
gave birth to their first child miles
shortly after the series ended in 2001.
the transition to motherhood wasn't an
easy one in an interview with camera
conversations o'connor explained i had
been busy for so many years for six
years working 80 to 90 hours a week and
then suddenly that was all gone and it
was just a baby and myself
after her marriage to mirror ended
o'connor married jed sura who has
partnered with her on many projects the
two share a daughter iris sura o'connor
both of her children inherited the
acting bug performing in her production
watched the sky alongside their mom iris
also had a role in roc productions
infinity and miles was in an episode of
the show my life is murder
after the finale of xena warrior
princess renee o'connor acted in a
number of low-budget b movies and
monster films one such flick was alien
apocalypse in which she starred opposite
horror and b-movie legend bruce campbell
the film is exactly what it sounds like
an apocalypse movie that takes place
after aliens have taken over earth the
two stars shared a kiss in the film
which campbell deemed so wheat in a
tweet isn't she something unsurprisingly
fans were graced with this union of cult
icons because the two have a solid
connection with mr sam raimi executive
producer of hercules legendary journeys
and xena warrior princess and it's
thanks to campbell's long professional
relationship with raymie that he landed
the recurring role of atollicus well
let's hope he's at least as debonair and
charming as i am or no one will be
fooled
renee o'connor also branched out into
live theater she took on the role of
lady macbeth in 2002 but according to
broadway world she didn't fully get into
a theater career until 15 years later in
addition to playing lady macbeth more
than once o'connor has played the nurse
in a production of romeo and juliet in
which her son miles muir held the role
of romeo though she's had roles in
multiple shakespearean plays in classics
like annie mary poppins and the wizard
of oz she's also starred in more modern
dramas in 2017 o'connor joined the cast
of dinner with friends at littlefish
theater she has played a number of roles
at the venue including the lead and
steven dietz on clover road just like
her hollywood career o'connor expanded
her live theater one by sitting in the
director's chair she helmed a production
of romeo and juliet sharing the
experience with fans in an instagram
post of herself directing on stage
next renee o'connor founded her own
non-profit theater company house of
bards located in san pedro in addition
to producing she typically takes a dual
role either acting in or directing the
productions according to broadway world
house of bart's theater company's first
production was macbeth in 2019 starring
o'connor and her husband jed sura as the
leads surah co-founded the theater
company with o'connor and has been
partnering on projects since well before
its conception house of bards presented
its second play with romeo and juliet
the same production o'connor directed
which had its last show in may of 2022
renee o'connor's artistic ability goes
beyond the screen and stage during the
lockdown she updated her official
website with an art page full of
paintings she made she would use a
mixture of beeswax and resin crystals
combined with pigments to create layers
of translucent colors that form an
overall image this wasn't the first time
o'connor has demonstrated her love of
painting in an interview with hobo
trashcan she revealed that she used the
money she earned from selling paintings
to help fund her first production
venture diamonds and guns that film came
out in 2008 so it's clear that painting
has been another creative outlet for the
former xena warrior princess star for
quite some time
if you assumed that spending six years
opposite each other on a world-renowned
hit tv series would make renee o'connor
and lucy lawless pretty tight you aren't
wrong while the xena warrior princess
stars can go years at a time without
seeing each other they have nonetheless
stayed good friends following the series
when asked about their relationship in
an interview with the toronto star
lawless revealed that very much like
their xena warrior princess roles it's a
sisterhood it's beyond friends forged in
the heat of battle xena warrior princess
was filmed in new zealand lala's home
country and where she still resides
o'connor on the other hand is an
american who relocated to transform into
gabrielle for the series she returned to
the states after the show ended which
put quite the physical distance between
the two stars but they've always found
ways to reconnect
renee o'connor traveled to new zealand
during the lockdown to reunite with her
former co-star when she accepted a
one-off role in lawless's acorn tv
mystery series my life is murder in 2021
o'connor appeared in an episode as the
wife of a health guru who ends up dead
the xena warrior princess alums found
themselves going head-to-head in my life
as murder rather than fighting together
like the good old days a refreshing
change for the two friends according to
an interview the reunited stars gave to
entertainment weekly it had been a while
since they'd seen each other this
combined with o'connor wearing a mask
made it so lawless didn't even recognize
her at first despite that and the fact
that o'connor hadn't been on a tv set in
quite some time the on-screen reunion
was easy going it just felt like walking
into lucy's living room and having
friends over it was so charming and
loving and it was like that all the way
to the very end i actually had a little
withdrawal when i finished filming
my life as murder isn't the only recent
collaboration between the former xena
warrior princess stars prior to their
reunion on lucy lawless's show the two
actors reunited remotely for their
series 25th anniversary sci-fi fangirls
put together a five-episode podcast that
was a total blast from the past for both
fans and those involved in xena just as
stars like bruce campbell and ted raymie
return to talk about their time on the
show o'connor and lawless have their own
episode together in episode 2 of the
xena warrior princess 25th anniversary
podcast the two reminisced about all the
less than ideal conditions of filming
the series in new zealand lucy lawless
recounts the time rats were dumped on
her while filming an uncomfortable scene
saying she had them up her xena skirt
and spiders in her mouth while that
might sound like a horrifying day
looking back on the situation together
seems like it was a lot more fun for the
co-stars
rene o'connor and lucy lawless seemed to
have gone through the ringer when they
were filming xena warrior princess but
you wouldn't expect anything less from
two killer amazonian warriors as it
turns out the stars also became lesbian
icons after they appeared as xena and
gabrielle o'connor was voted lesbian
nation's most loved woman in 2006
beating out lawless who still came in
second in 2007 their places swapped the
series hints at a romantic relationship
between xena and gabrielle even though
it never became canon that the two were
together however after the series ended
lawless made the truth about the
relationship clear telling siriusxm in
2010 that xena and gabrielle were a
couple
when speaking to page six about the
lesbian undertones of xena warrior
princess o'connor said she felt that if
the show were on today the characters
would have no need to only hint at their
relationship are you in love with
gabrielle
[Music]
although it was only implied it was
still groundbreaking for the time
something that the lgbtq community could
latch onto as a kind of representation
in mainstream media
although gabrielle and xena's
relationship was a hot topic back when
the show was on the air the characters
are still very much beloved by their
loyal fan base o'connor and lawless have
both attended their fair share of
conventions for xena warrior princess
over the years giving the former
co-stars opportunities to catch up with
fans and each other fan events and
conventions take o'connor and lawless
all over the map but for two people who
live thousands of miles away from each
other they're pretty much the perfect
excuse to be in the same city during
multi-day events the two actors tend to
appear on the same day to greet fans and
answer questions this was exemplified by
creation entertainment's 2022 salute to
xena event which celebrated the series
quarter-century milestone both actors
enjoy interacting with the convention
crowds during the 2018 fan expo canada
in toronto lawless thrilled attendees by
calling o'connor her screen wife all
these years post xena the two stars
still have a great time together and
with their fans
[Music]